hello welcome to this video playing swap
the national master Malaya from Germany
assign quite frequent opponent I musk
Weiss not good yeah man plus free but
I'm usually such a huge rating favorite
against them that this is really not
great somehow some are not a good
matchup I mean okay I've got a taraji
i'm playing a slightly unusual line but
this is not all that bad III is possible
but not great is it night before I
wonder
right if forward what do I play against
I can actually grab no I cannot crap
what do I play against bishop 5 in this
position this is what bothered me a
little bit hmm I forgot to take on c6
actually this is the thing then I'm then
I'm winning this pawn or keeping this
pawn that's very bad ah this isn't good
now not at all forgot to take here then
black as a pawn down for not very much I
shoot what can I do now
oh it's pretty awful actually instead of
being better jan was check ok I don't
think that this was the most dangerous
continuation right hard to say
at least now I'm somewhat active here
with my pieces the colony to is not a
big issue yeah this is maybe maybe a
decent IDM trying to wrap that Bishop
but um my development is very good so
that's not all that easy for him
it invites me to do this with a tempo
here mmm is there reason not to do it in
supergroup the eight then this is a self
pinner that this it shouldn't be
forgotten
and I probably still you cannot take it
loses the bishops oh yes you go look at
the age I am what why I said move don't
get it Oh is he just giving it up
another bishop is saying and the rookie
saying and there is no no big idea here
black resigns okay and it was very lucky
I I completely confused was confused
here here here i forgot to insert the
bishop capture him this is the i forgot
to do this and now this this is a big
difference now and threatening night
takes f6 now destroying his King side
position like Knight takes pawn takes
and then Bishop takes you unknown on d4
and here after Bishop to e7 which is the
best move wyd retains the position with
the pawn up for example I can do this
and this doesn't look like much I mean
there is this double porn but I have a
very good bishop on the form and a
controlled c5 and I can play against the
C porn this is not the losing four black
or something but white can work with
this for an opening result I think he
can be very happy with it um yeah I
forgot I forgot that I just forgot it
and played here and now this isn't all
that grade because he keeps his
structure and I just see anything better
like that I was it looks like surprised
that year I thought you should take with
the night and set it with the Queen yeah
and here I don't know this is still not
that easy for black I think if you go
back or something like that your you
just drew is young after 96 so he has to
do some things concrete it cannot just
like okay I'm going
back in the engine just to take and now
gives a very good move I think that I
did not see at all and this is f 5 okay
now that's pretty good I mean I can do
this form equality or something you know
this is probably something that is equal
I will get this back basically and I'm
active rooks go get little trade and I
will get the pawn back the engine gives
equal I can try after a five to play
something more enterprising like this
but then he has this square interesting
the engine needs to play like that was
really a pretty cool line who can't King
f4 and I'm poured down but this is quite
serious compensation interesting yeah
this I'm not sure about it looked fairly
logical to get rid of this strong bishop
but it's not quite clear how he's
supposed to play him the engine suggests
this which is something like that is
what I also expected and okay I'm very
active here the night looks good the
rook is dangerous looking on c7 but it's
not entirely clear how I'm making
something out of that black is very
solid yet here he can still go look the
eight I mean he gets the same kind of
position just tempe down like this is
what the engine wants to do and I can
this is very annoying to play but he has
to learn plenty some he's a piece down
okay thanks and thanks for watching yeah